jetzt mal eine wirklich persönliche
Frage sind sie auch schon voll im
Fußballfieber ja von heute angerechnet
sind es nur noch
596 Tage bis zur Europameisterschaft in
Deutschland
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wobei nee warte mal Deutschland ist doch
dieses Land da ständig waffenliefert ein
total problematische Länder oder
natürlich Waffen für Krisengebiete
dann muss man das natürlich auch
boykottieren 2024 aber eins nach dem
anderen meiner Damen und Herren jetzt
boykottieren wir erstmal die WM in Katar
Meldung von heute
ja ganz aktuelle Meldung Qatar bestellt
den deutschen Botschafter ein wegen
Nancy fesers katakritic Thema
Menschenrechte und ich hoffe in wenigen
Minuten werde ich auch eingestellt meine
Damen und Herren ne übermorgen in drei
Wochen geht's los passenderweise am
Totensonntag ja Tatsache das
Eröffnungsspiel Katar gegen Ecuador also
der klassiko
und wir stimmen Sie heute schon mal ein
mit Gianni Infantino FIFA Chef und
begnadeter Comedian
wo immer wir hingehen in dieser Welt
stellen wir den Schutz der
Menschenrechte in den Vordergrund
Johnny Infantino mit seinem neuen
Comedy-Programm I'm funny I'm Johnny oh
Gott ja der Emil von Katar hat sich
diese Woche beklagt kein WM-Gastgeber
sei jemals so angegangen worden wie
Katar ja aus Gründen Herr
nur mal zur Erinnerung Katar hat damals
nachweislich die schlechteste
WM-Bewerbung von allen eingereicht und
trotzdem den Zuschlag gekriegt warum
genau dieser Frage geht seit Jahren ein
heute-show investigativteam nach und wir
fassen jetzt mal alle Erkenntnisse und
Indizien für Sie zusammen wie haben die
Kataris das geschafft
[Musik]
aha ja
das waren jetzt natürlich viele Fakten
auf einmal
aber es ist halt auch ein komplexes
Thema
DWM wurde gekauft und das trotz der
berühmten FIFA Ethikkommission es gibt
wirklich eins meiner absoluten
lieblingsleute FIFA Ethikkommission
klingt so wie katharischer
frauenbeauftragter oder da fällt mir ein
kennen sie schon das neue FIFA 23 Spiel
ich habe es gestern mal durchgespielt
und muss sagen was stinkt langweilig ja
da werden die ganze Zeit nur Geldkoffer
in der Wüste übergeben
noch mehr Koffer zwischendurch kommt
kurz Gianni in fatino bemerkt aber
nichts Verbotenes und geht wieder nach
Hause mehr ist es nicht mir ist es nicht
leider viel zu realistisch das Spiel
klar was gekaufte Weltmeisterschaften
angeht sind Deutschland in der Mutter
aller Glashäuser nur wir haben unsere
viel günstiger gekauft
hallo Herr Kaiser im übrigen
im übrigen sind wir deutschen eigentlich
die letzten die sich mit Katar anlegen
dürften denn wir gehören den quasi das
ist kein Witz Deutsche Bank Siemens VW
die kaufen hier alles auf und sind
unsere neuen besten Freunde wie dieser
40 Jahre alte Beitrag erschreckend
präzise vorhergesagt hat erdgas ist die
Energiequelle der Zukunft und Kata
besitzt hier unbegrenzte Reserven davon
Kattas Reserven könnten gerade für uns
Westeuropäer eines Tages die Alternative
zu den sibirischen Erdgas vorkommen
werden 19
82 wie schade dass Olaf Scholz den
Beitrag damals nicht gesehen hat
andererseits er hätte ihn eh wieder
vergessen
zumindest wenn ein
Untersuchungsausschuss fragt so aber
jetzt mal zurück zum Projekt
wm-vorfreude zerstören völlig abgesehen
von dem Irrsinn klimatisierte Stadien
mitten in der Wüste zu bauen ist Katar
natürlich ein durch und durch
autokratischer Staat ein Staat der für
sein Leben gern im Media Markt einkauft
in diesem Kontrollzentrum laufen die
Signale von rund 15.000
Überwachungskameras ein wir können in
die Menge reinzoomen und jeden Fan
identifizieren das ist eine
Vorsichtsmaßnahme und hilft uns falls
ein Unglück passiert oder falls sich
Fans nicht richtig verhalten genau also
Leute
überwachungsstart hin oder her aber das
publikum-film ist ja wohl das
hinterletzte gibt es denn gar keine
Grenzen mehr gibt es denn gar keine
Grenzen mehr
der Typ auf 3C hat nicht gelacht
jeder WM-Besucher in Katar muss sich vor
Einreise zwei Apps auf sein Handy laden
darunter eine corona-app die den
Standort trackt und vollen
Speicherzugriff fordert ach ja und
Journalisten kriegen vor dem Turnier
eine ganze Liste von Sachen die sie
ausdrücklich nicht filmen dürfen
Liebe Medien herzlich willkommen in
Katar und nur ein winziger Hinweis in
keinem Fall Filmen dürfen sie
Regierungsgebäude religiöse
Einrichtungen Universitäten
Krankenhäuser einheimische in ihren
privaten Räumen Baustellen Gastarbeiter
qatarinnen ach am besten beschränken Sie
sich auf Bilder wie das das hier gern
auch das hier es sei denn die Kamele
sind schwul dann auch nicht und jetzt
viel Spaß beim berichten welcome to
Katar
ja
tatsächlich darf man alles nicht filmen
mal ganz ehrlich bei dieser WM wäre es
mir lieber wenn man die Spiele nicht
filmen dürfte ja in Stadien für deren
Bau Arbeitsmigranten 17 bis 18 Stunden
am Tag schuften mussten Arbeitsmigranten
den man die Pässe weggenommen hat die
oft monatelang keinen Lohn gekriegt
haben untergebracht in total verdreckten
Löchern wie dem hier wie viele genau auf
den stadionbaustellen gestorben sind das
weiß keiner sicher ist viel zu viele das
sogenannte kavala-system also letztlich
Zwangsarbeit ist zwar in Katar offiziell
seit 2014 abgeschafft aber richtig
kontrolliert wurde das nie und noch vor
wenigen Wochen haben Arbeiter schon
wieder gegen lohndiebstahl protestiert
kurz gesagt
menschenverachtender geht es kaum oder
in den Worten des FIFA chefkomikers wenn
Sie jemandem Arbeit geben auch wenn er
in einer schwierigen Lage ist verleihen
sie ihm Würde und Stolz
oh Gott wirklich
Winterschlussverkauf bei der FIFA Stolz
und Würde für nur zwei Euro 55
katarischer Mindestlohn und noch mal zum
Mitschreiben noch nie hat irgendein
Sport-Event irgendwas nachhaltig
verbessert in irgendeiner Diktatur also
außer die WM 2018 in Russland natürlich
seitdem ist das ein total knuffiges Land
was mir was mir allerdings gefällt ist
das Maskottchen der WM in Katar kennen
sie das
schon süß oder laep ist ja so eine Art
weißer Lappen und weil die Ataris keine
Ahnung von Fußball haben hat er nicht
mal Füße
ja hallo hier Hand gespielt haben die
wissen nicht mal was Handspiel ist gibt
Elfmeter du Honk was soll der sein ah
jetzt verstehe ich ist der Geist der
beim Stadionbau gestorbenen
Arbeitsmigranten oder vielleicht ist
aber auch der Blanco Check den Katar als
Bewerbung bei der FIFA eingereicht hat
nein jetzt habe ich es erinnern sie noch
angoleo unser doofes Maskottchen 2006
Betrieb ist die verlorene Unterhose von
boleum nach 16 Jahren endlich
aufgetaucht
kalte Milch
Goleo so trotz allem was wir in den
letzten Minuten gehört haben lassen sich
jede Menge prominente vor den pr-karren
der katar-wm spannen also die lassen
sich letztlich kaufen reden wir darüber
mit der heute-show netzreporterin und
influencerin Larissa Larissa was sind
das bitte für Stars die sich von Katar
kaufen lassen ja hallo liebe Leute ich
bin's Larissa ein netzreporterin und
ihre diesbezügliche Frage Herr Oliver
finde ich ist sehr gut weil für mich
sind Menschenrechte definitiv ganz klar
auf jeden Fall einen Menschenrecht weil
ja weil jeder hat das Recht ein Mensch
zu sehen außer natürlich Tiere und
Pflanzen und Aliens aber ich sag mal so
selbstsicher Oliver ich schwöre auch sie
sind für mich ein Mensch
also im weitesten Sinne
ich glaube ja vielen Dank sehr gerne ja
und
deshalb haben gewesen
Bild zu machen ich habe sogar mehrere
Bilder gemacht ich schwöre ja mit meinem
neuen Handy hier guck also das bin ich
in Doha und das bin ich auch in Doha da
trinke ich eh so ein frozen Joghurt der
war sehr bekömmlich und hier guck mal
wie süß ich da guck oder voll süß ja
also was viele zum Beispiel gar nicht
wissen das will ich jetzt mal sagen wenn
man nach Doha fliegt und dann im
Internet sagt oh du meine Güte hier ist
voll schön weichendora dann kommt ein
Mann und der gibt dann einem Schmuck aus
purem Gold ja ich schwöre einfach so ich
meine in welchen anderen Land bekommt
man bitte Schmuck ich meine in keine
Ahnung Dänemark vielleicht wobei nein
glaube ich nicht nein aber das meine ich
doch dafür wollen die cataris ja eine
Gegenleistung von Leuten wie dir oder
von David Beckham man sich die Skyline
ansieht für mich zeigt das den
Fortschritt den das Land in so kurzer
Zeit gemacht hat und dabei trotzdem
seine Geschichte behält sein Erbe und
das was wirklich zählt das was für David
Beckham wirklich zählt ist
wahrscheinlich das Geld umgerechnet 180
Millionen Euro
180 Millionen Euro ja das klingt jetzt
erstmal sehr viel aber Vorsicht Herr
Oliver Vorsicht erstes Mal waren das für
den David nicht nur einer sondern zwei
Drehtage dann war das auch noch voll
warm gewesen und da musste voll viele
Sachen machen da musst du zum Beispiel
ganz allein mit einem Boot fahren dabei
muss der gut aussehen später musst du
sogar noch Fußball spielen mit ein
fremden Frau und gucken Sie mal die Frau
sie ist aus Katar aber sie darf alleine
draußen sein ohne Leine damit haben sie
jetzt nicht gerechnet oder denk da mal
drüber nach Herr Lügenpresse
Mariah Carey Lothar Matthäus es ist
unglaublich wer alles für diese scheiß
WM Werbung macht hier Lothar wird auf
seiner Facebook-Seite ernsthaft für eine
von den blöden Apps die man sich als
WM-Besucher runterladen muss ich sage
ein Lothar Matthäus sollte mal dringend
in sich gehen auch wenn dann
wahrscheinlich keinen Antrieb meine
Larissa Werbung für ein Land wo auf
Homosexualität die Todesstrafe stehen
kann was ich habe gerade nicht zu ganz
ich bin gerade bei tiktok ich muss
gerade unbedingt noch ganz schnell mit
ihnen ein Video für tik tok machen
kommen Sie mal her Gott warten sie hallo
liebe Leute hier ist eure Larissa und
ich bin gerade in diese alte Leute
Sendung ja mit den dicken Mann hier und
er sagt dass er sich auch voll auf die
WM in Katar freut also bis bald und
liebe Grüße an Emil von mir nicht
Larissa meine Damen und Herren vielen
Dank
Larissa ja
gekaufte influencerin
gut auf der Habenseite ist es schon
durchaus beeindruckend wie viele
deutsche Städte in diesem Jahr kein
Public Viewing anbieten sportkneipen
boykottieren die Weltmeisterschaft und
auch viele Fans steigen aus oder sie
versuchen es zumindest Alexander
Wipprecht ist Hardcore Fußballfan aber
in diesem Jahr ist alles anders sorry
ich bin raus man kann als wm-zuschauer
kein menschenverachtendes System
unterstützen also ARD und ZDF Spaß
ich meine natürlich Katar und die FIFA
da könnte ich nicht mehr in den Spiegel
gucken
ein ganzes Fanleben einfach wegwerfen
vielen deutschen fällt das in diesen
Tagen schwerer als gedacht
82 natürlich ist es auch so eine Art
Entzug was man dadurch macht
heißt aber auch mehr quality haben mit
der Familie heute kochen wir zum
Beispiel zusammen Schatz gibt es mir mal
den Humus ja klar
und ich habe auch überhaupt kein Problem
damit das gerade ein nations League
Spiel mit deutscher Beteiligung läuft
dass alle meine Kumpels gerade in der
sportkneipe gucken
wo ist das Problem das Laufen noch
andere tolle Sachen im Fernsehen
[Musik]
okay was gibt es in der Mediathek
du bist die Idiot wer mit einem
fußballabhängigen lebt muss allerdings
wissen ein Entzug funktioniert leider
nie ohne Rückschläge übrigens ich habe
gestern mit Mama telefoniert und
bevor das mit Elements das wird immer
schlimmer wahrscheinlich musste jetzt
doch ins Heim
beziehungsweise oh mein Gott das ist ja
furchtbar aber deine arme Mama WM
Boykott 2022 vergesst es einfach
[Applaus]
und stehe ich richtig super also dann
los
liebe Fans der feinsten Unterhaltung
klickt hier hin wenn ihr weitere Videos
sehen wollt
das war's super take wir haben es ich
sehe auch echt schick aus heute